yeah no one to welcome to see your plane
on from the US guess you get the Marathi
it's a good opening to play late in the
night of the day and ya can and people
know that by now yeah this is a good
line okay so it should be six and for
most people don't know that this is the
most critical one okay I guess night III
is early I mean it often goes to a three
later when there's real pressure on Z
forward this is an early stage
[Music]
right angle 965 here or queen a five
okay I think this is okay this should be
the first of all I'm threatening the
bishops III nitec you form okay I wonder
if it's best maybe to go all the way
back so that there is no tactic based on
Bishop c5 I want to play khooneh five in
some cases yeah but I'm not question
what is next with anyway so let's go
Bishop d7 now if all is definitely
hanging and I also have the e5 square
now
yeah let's show how he holds all this
Bishop at three maining but taking on c3
is an option and Queen 85 or queen 85
immediately also is a as an idea
they I think it all extended here but ok
so is there anything like some concrete
measures I wonder i can take and go 95
it possible and then Queen a fun and who
are really a bishop is not bad maybe
Queen 85 immediately I mean just like
look I think it's that it's the thing i
will probably have a decent position
with many moves
that's true and the real argument why
and maybe should have taken yeah yeah it
was probably better okay I mean I don't
think I'm in bad shape but definitely
not not ideal maybe we should be one
maybe I should have taken the bishop by
the way just to activate them the bishop
on d3 doesn't look great but I still was
having less space some are quite happy
mmm quite happy about trading everyone
I'm taking this now I have 94 stuff so
Queenie to on windy one is more or less
mandatory 95 maybe is annoying huh just
just saw it
and even there should be six is now part
of this oh my objection such a [ __ ]
yeah I was pretty it was a pretty good
position at the beginning don't think
that this was any good really hope I'm
not getting my queen trapped in or
something it could be app that goodies
on the Apple okay I don't know why you
did that but okay that looked like it
helped me now that's not you for Bishop
g4 possible okay
how do I actually cover this this is B 6
square Luke c6 looks completely wrong my
dad Bishop g5 or something
[Music]
if I go b-52 should be six Queen 84 it
looks like it has no squares Nazi three
quick before no then actually takes the
form okay if you trust my queen come on
hey it said then that just what it is I
don't see it I don't see how it wraps it
and if you cannot then this is a good
move ok so can take him to light is
vulnerable they're just trying to
prevent them we should be three and
Bishop before now as a threat you just
had detected seven so i couldn't could
not fly Bishop before immediately time
money I take it the 95 is just extremely
nice control and d5 is a week
I didn't see that one coming ok that's
the Queen quite a while now I'm still
not happy there that is the position out
of the opening looked really good and
then somehow somehow it didn't know
about I must have really done something
wrong yeah after I thought here should
be good yet it looks weird I should take
em let them that was really miss sexy
one so I should take one I still have
the opportunity and Jake win 8 5 when
the post rupture is absolutely terrible
i am I just let my bishop click this
this knack is sorry the night is hanging
that's good for black Aaron I am NOT
getting checkmated their own some and
this is not that wasn't all that great
relief can I try that it's crazy I need
to take some precautions against this
and all of a sudden all of a sudden and
96 Bishop b6 it's crazy that he has
nothing there I mean if if sites would
have been reversed yeah I bet the
headlight here I would be totally I
would be totally sure that there should
be something against the Queen er
there's nothing cuter wants to draw the
should be six Bishop e3 and that that
cannot cannot help and now it seems he
has no trap there I mean I saw that this
is possible of course but it's not
trapping it okay and yeah I'm all of a
sudden in good shape boy that's a
CAPTCHA really i didn't see that tattoo
I have no good move them and was lucky
then now here's the better black
coordination is just really nice but
again ii p held on oh that's nicer i
missed this move okay i can just take
because of the week back point that's
it's funny and of course i can take I
don't know why I didn't take it actually
paid off because i'm on the queen but
yeah i was a bit a bit shaky at the end
ok guys thanks for watching